you're the process of manufacturer in
the NFL football starts out with the
side of a cow I'll get about ten
footballs out of each side so we get
about twenty footballs out of each cow
these hides come from Kansas Nebraska
Iowa go to Chicago to the weather
processor and they come in to me looking
like this they have the pebble in them
they have the tack so this is what's
actually gonna be on the outside the
ball the way it comes in feeling
whatever we're stamping with stamping
Wilson NFL today so these guys the thumb
of heat and pressure makes an impression
and the black foil is relief the gold
foil and then another block so the
entire panel gets stamped at the same
time we then so the product together
inside out so we don't those seams
showing what those seem to be inside
after we get the ball so together inside
out you have to turn it right-side out
to where the laces are going to be to do
it on this bar put it in that steam box
add boiling water in it makes it softer
and more pliable this is very difficult
to work with
with your hands we crush the ends turn
the ball right side out we go from here
to here
before that ball goes down FL we have to
make sure it's soaked properly it's
laced properly the bladder is good it's
inspected 100% the sewing has to be
perfect I think my proudest moment every
year is when they kick off the Super
Bowl knowing that that ball came from
800 hi oh these dedicated he workers
here manufactured that was really sweat
muscle it's a hard product to make so
when they kick that Super Bowl ball and
that's my finest moment every year
you